so what is the most important lesson you
took out of being a founder in your
company well I learned business lessons
right there are things that I've learned
about running a company that I think
we're valuable I've written a bunch
about this sort of saying don't rely on
one channel to acquire all your
customers and if you do know the risks
when you're young as a company you have
to rely on things to a to a degree
that's probably not healthy and you got
to make that trade and no work came from
actually Google did the same thing right
Google's Yahoo deal when Yahoo was
sending them all their search traffic
though I mean that made the company and
Yahoo pulled the contract or said no I
think Larry and Sergey would be in a
different place I mean maybe they they
probably would've figured it out because
it's them but you know so that's that's
a trade you got to make but for me
personally I think I just learned a lot
about what I'm good at when a bad at how
to manage people how to manage
co-founders and work with co-founders
like people who are your equals but you
have to keep them on track which is very
difficult especially as a CEO where
they're keeping you on track you're
keeping them on track that's a really
tough thing to manage and from a product
point of view what is like your insights
know your customer really well we built
the wrong product at first because we
had a conception of our customer that
wasn't accurate I think in terms of how
we initially built our marketplace and I
think we didn't understand our customer
quite well enough and we didn't really
solve our own problem when we started
and I think we should have I think we
would have been a more successful
company had we Hulme closer to our own
real deep problems because we lost a lot
of iteration cycles on that so if I were
to start another company if I left Y
Combinator and started a company I think
it would be something that I understood
more intimately as someone who like
experienced that thing right so why
would I want to be an entrepreneur I
don't know that you do you know it's a
funny thing I think that people give
different answers to this question
because I think it's actually different
for different people I don't think
there's one way that you can look and
say ah I checked these boxes I know I
want to be an entrepreneur for
me it was a question of degree of
control you know I had worked at
companies beforehand and just never felt
like I was actually influencing the
success or failure of those companies or
the vision of those companies and I
wasn't happy with that I play well with
others but I'm not great at being
managed depending on who the manager is
so so that's something that indicates
maybe I should be a founder and I wanted
to do something really large that was
kind of outsized to the opportunity set
offered by working in a company you know
we kind of look at startups as the most
most rapid way to impact the largest
number of people in the world to think
that you know Facebook went from nothing
in 2005 to having 1.3 billion monthly
active users in 10 years is astonishing
there's nothing else on earth that I
think has reached that many people that
quickly I think the closest examples are
probably religion right and those take
centuries to hit that many people at
that deeper part of their life it's it's
technology that can do that you know
radio and television before that and now
it's it's startups on the internet so
passion has a big part of it huge I mean
you have to believe in what you're doing
or really want to do it you know I think
there are people who found companies not
because they're particularly passionate
but because they see a really great
opportunity for making money and I think
that that's always in there somewhere
for people starting companies you know
they want to be billionaires or
something like that but I think for the
most part the people who really succeed
are the people who aren't doing it
because of the money itself there was a
there was a great quote or a great thing
that I heard when I was on Wall Street
we're just both good and bad there's
like good and bad to this statement but
a lot of people there say that money
isn't the goal it's not how you win the
game it's how you keep score
right right and I think that's true for
a lot of people they're not actually
earning money for money safe they're
earning money because it's the metric
right it's the proxy for showing that
you built something huge something huge
and valuable so I think that if your
drive is to
change lots and lots of people daily
lives how they work or impact a lot of
people then you should probably try to
start a company you know if you want
just more autonomy in your life start a
company it doesn't have to be a start-up
right it can be a business right like a
small business that gives you freedom in
your life that's amazing
you know don't fetishize the idea of of
startups and these things that will
touch everyone if you just want to build
something with your own hands I think
fundamentally that's what it comes down
to very cool starting company